all right pippy
hey Pippi uh where did you grow up where
are you from
I grew up on the east coast in a small
town in North Carolina oh really yeah
tell me about your family
uh well uh I'm pretty estranged from
everybody at this point I'm the last
child out uh my mom was not
prepared she was she didn't want to have
have me
I mean that's just I was kind of an on
the sixth the number six
uh so we all had to kind of make our way
in the world and however
uh whatever that that meant and growing
up where I did being effeminate
was uh wow it was hell because I got
picked on by everybody but even my
mostly my family so I didn't have a
support network of any kind uh there
that's what led me to uh moving away and
ending up in Atlanta
and eventually uh San Francisco and now
Southern California California West
Coast is probably easier yeah after
after covid uh San Francisco just got to
be
really unbearable
the homeless situation is out of control
I was becoming homeless myself I wasn't
making any money and
um yeah and I was trying to get sober so
sober from alcohol alcohol
um there are some drugs in my history
but uh and the fact that I didn't do as
many as a lot of my peers probably is
what kept me drinking because I would
say at least I'm not a drug addict you
know but
I know I know I know now that addiction
is addiction to whatever whatever it may
be uh the alcohol powder the liquids
whatever and uh now recently I've I've
not recently but I mean I see that
it's so Insidious that it can kind of
manipulate and move around like I said
maybe you're done with alcohol but we're
gonna do sexual
obsessive or uh you know there's not so
many other ways that we can [ __ ] up our
lives is available everywhere and very
accepted oh yeah for sure that I mean I
think like the con like addictive
behavior can uh manifest in uh so many
other way other ways like compulsive
gambling or whatever what other
behaviors do you have well I can do them
all really you know I could if
compulsive gambling is a p i mean what I
think because it
gives you that status when you win of
course that's your trigger that's like
you know it's like a high it's like a
rush you know you could win a thousand
dollars and then
spend two thousand dollars to try to get
more so you you get involved in gambling
as well sometimes yeah yeah I mean uh I
had to leave the town I was in Palm
Springs for a while and it was so easy
that has a casino there and uh it's easy
to get I there's something that happens
when I walk in
uh to a casino there's a kind of
thrill or adrenaline or whatever and
since I've won there before I go to the
machine where I went on before and of
course I
it lets you it's very it lets you win a
few times and then you start losing so
you're just like up to down I mean
obviously I mean I think you know that
when you go in I mean they can't build
these Grand casinos with all the lights
and attractions without making a lot of
money so uh clearly there has to be a
way more losers than there are winners
and I've found out that even the winners
have spent thousands and thousands to
get the winnings that they got and
chances are they never uh they don't
stop gambling you know like I want you
win ten thousand dollars
terrific does that mean you're gonna
invest that money wisely and never get
gamble again of course not because
it's so much of a thrill I mean the the
town of Las Vegas is built upon that
premise so I mean uh it's one of it it
prays plays on our human instinct our
desire or whatever right what kind of
jobs or careers have you had in your
life
uh I've done a lot where
um
you have easy access to alcohol uh
bartending you know and Catering
bartending is probably the uh the best
way to uh have easy access to alcohol
and most of the time
there's not very many consequences
either although uh the the fact is that
the consequences started presenting
themselves more and more um
like everything in life it's cute when
you're young and pretty and people look
the other way about crazy behavior or
whatever but uh
towards the end of my drinking it was
just uh you know I knew how much trouble
I'd cause and get into and I black out
or they don't know what I'm doing or
saying and I could be uh aggressive or
you know make a sexual Advance on
somebody who's totally not into it or
anything and and just be uh but for
years that was an acceptable behavior
because I was around a bunch of other
people who were [ __ ] ups and party
people and you know the world is ending
let's party hard
um for a long time I mean that whole
idea of the looming apocalypse kind of
what is what my incentive was but now
that the apocalypse really is here
my mind well like the 90s the 80s and
90s is when the AIDS pandemic really uh
seemed unsolvable and it basically
seemed
um
like an inevitable death sentence and uh
for many years
I assumed that I was going to have HIV
or that I had HIV uh and I never
bothered to get tested because I didn't
want to know I just wanted to die uh
dramatically or quickly you know
suddenly
but of course it doesn't play that play
out that way I saw many people who did
die of AIDS and who suffered long and
slow deaths and it was pretty miserable
and uh someone who like myself who's
prone to depression and anxiety anyway
it was easy to just turn to alcohol and
you know a lot of these friends of mine
who were facing terminal illness they're
like
let's let's go out let's party either
side develop the attitude of like let's
live fast Die Young etc etc I'm not
young anymore though so now I'm it's
like what's what's going to be my my
third Act
I don't have any money or savings and
you know
uh try I I do get jobs as a kind of
freaky uh character in in videos online
and and even
um major movies and TV shows I mean I
get booked as a background extra but uh
obviously uh that's not consistent it's
not great money and the dream is to get
something that turns into something
bigger but where do you live now
uh to High Desert Mojave Desert okay so
outside of La so
uh until recently I had my own my car
but it overheated and so
I'm kind of desperate for money in a new
car but uh the I could drive into La for
a job and it wasn't it wasn't that bad a
big of a deal today I was able to borrow
a car so
um
Yeah you mentioned to me earlier that
you're a hoarder as well
yeah
um it's just something that that I know
is it
I've watched the show orders and it's
been very Illuminating but my aunt is a
hoarder and and uh I remember growing up
how we all kind of criticized her about
that we didn't know what the term the
term was not really discussed
but uh and it's very frustrating to try
to explain it to other people like you
know you're up to your chin and crap
but you can't let it go and you don't
know why and it's really frustrating so
it separates you from people uh you
don't want people to come over and see
the place where you live because it's
embarrassing and of course they would
wonder well why would you want to live
that way and the answer is
you don't want to live that way but uh
you feel like you can't escape from it
so is it related in any way to gambling
or alcoholism I'd say so yeah I think
they all uh kind of play in together
um in fact the the more I was drinking
the less I was hoarding so now that I'm
not drinking these other bad
aspects of my character coming to the
Forefront what other what other bad
aspects well the stealing the
kleptomania um so
you know uh you when you do it it's
that's kind of a thrill so you're a
kleptomaniac as well yeah and it's so
easy to uh get around like
if you have your if your wits about like
San Francisco has become a town they
just stopped Prosecuting it so it's
basically an open invitation for first I
mean it almost takes the fun out of it
to be uh it's because like there's
really no repercussions so you'll steal
from stores you can just steal anything
from uh like CVS or uh you know do you
do that too like our Target or whatever
people that you know or people you meet
or anything like that or just stores
just the stores you know um
I feel like they uh oops they have a way
to bounce back or whatever they have a
network that they can recover somehow
but still it's like you can you even if
they have security cameras all over the
place a lot of times
you just become invisible when you get
to when you just dress roll down and I
mean if you don't call too much
attention to yourself every situation is
you know different you hopefully you can
size up
the circle the place when you arrive and
and can scope it out
but I think it's leading to
a lot more uh closures of stores they're
just not well they just can't handle it
anymore
especially in time that's one of the
reasons I left San Francisco is that so
out of control that the stores were
getting close we're closing down because
they couldn't keep up with all the
they couldn't handle the shoplifting
there was no uh no way to control it was
like they were hemorrhaging so many of
the homeless people support themselves
by stealing
oh yeah absolutely there's a whole
underground economy and then when you
live there you can just there I see it
around here too you can just walk on the
sidewalk and people have a little yard
sale going on where it's like yeah I got
this that the other if you need
something tell me what it is I can maybe
maybe find it for you so
it's it's almost it's like an untapped
resource in a way I mean MacArthur Park
here in La is is basically just a big
open market of stolen items yeah and
bicycles and you you name it and it's
like people have gotten locked into that
world that's the that's their job you
know that's their their thing so it's
almost like the system is so corrupt and
so rotten and that
it's it's unsolvable I mean it's really
hard to
get these people to change and go would
why it's like
there are a lot of people who complained
about marijuana becoming legal because
it was like bootlegging with alcohol uh
when alcohol was prohibited they there
were people who the Kennedys for example
made a huge Fortune from uh bootleg
alcohol
and now uh marijuana is legal and so
that underground economy is is erased
and
people
have had to adjust to that and deal with
it is there a relationship between your
kleptomania and your
according and your alcoholism and the
yeah I think gambling it fulfills that
some kind of a need that I don't even
know what it is
but uh yeah in your childhood what was
your relationship like with your dad he
died he died young so we didn't really
have a relationship I was only
eight years old at the time of his death
so uh my mother was very bitter about
her situation and she didn't want to
have children anyway did you feel loved
as a kid
no not really
um
I think she was able she could fake it
uh
but
I realized now I inherited her
personality which is
cold and distance ultimately and
just I'm [ __ ] up I really am and uh
I don't know what is going to happen to
me in the future it's scary because I
have no how old are you say 55.
would you know this is the age people
retire but
so it's a frightening cold and heartless
it feels like a heartless world out
there
especially when you're in the
underground like you think these
homeless people out here have a a coat
of Honor there is no code of honor well
I don't know what I mean people are it's
like being a wild animal and you know
it's survival and fighting and if you
have to
beat somebody up or even kill them to
get what you need you do it and you just
move on to the next thing
you live for the moment so
everybody has their time when they're
just vulnerable
and when you get that to that point you
don't you have no one to turn to when
you're living out on the street like
that you don't feel like you have any
allies
what's been your lowest point in your
life uh being homeless and having to
uh
be
nice or be sexual with people that I
just
turned not not turned on to at all but
because that I needed to do that in
order to uh
to have a place to stay and
dear friends
well I feel like I'm very alone in the
world at the moment so uh
I can have fake friends and
[ __ ] [ __ ] stuff like that but uh
you know there are meetings out there
you can go to support groups and stuff
and I do hit I hit those from time to
time but uh I just feel like I'm kind of
uh
a loner are those meetings helpful at
heart uh I think they can be for a
minute but uh they feel very uh empty
sometimes very
saccharin or something like that
hypocritical maybe I think that's the
that was the first thing I noticed about
people in church
uh growing up in the Bible Belt all the
hypocrisy and then
finding out later that they've been
molesting their their family or uh but
people are even you know they're
anti-gay but then they you know busted
doing having gay sex at like a rest stop
or something like that so
it's weird I almost think it's like a
fetish for some of these people to be uh
uh you know have two double live I
haven't done double life and all that
stuff so yeah I think it's pretty common
yeah totally and uh if you are smart and
think about these things it turns you
off to all of that it's hard to buy into
it right
you've been in love before
yeah who and they didn't love me back so
that happens that seems to be all I get
I always fall for the wrong uh wrong
person or the unavailable person
the people who are probably sociopaths
there's something that that I find
appealing about them or whatever uh
because they're distant or they're
they're broken and I feel like that's
somehow appealing
which is
stupid but I and I know what it is but
it is what it is it's a very common
human trait I think yeah you want the
unavailable yeah
well like the guy who was obsessed with
Jodie Foster yeah I mean that's the
first time I remember that somebody
having an obsession with someone who
didn't even know who they were or give a
[ __ ] about them
yeah I mean that was such a crazy story
but at the same time other people do it
people obsess about other people who
don't have any interest or even know who
they are you know
it's real twisted and I feel like it's
gotten even more so now maybe because we
have so much
information available and so little real
contact with each other
uh the coronavirus definitely made
things much worse and because we can't
be around each other safely but we can
stay home and watch TV and watch get on
the internet and go down the rabbit hole
of all these theories yeah celebrity is
a powerful commodity now
oh right well we're in the land of
celebrity right now and yeah
it seems that's a very more powerful
than
money power
anything it seems to be one of the most
powerful
aphrodisiacs there is
yeah and it's so stupid how quickly
people can become celebrities now via
the Internet uh you know children that
are like teenagers or even younger they
do a cute little video and next thing
you know uh millions of people are
subscribing or whatever
and it just happened so fast that if
they burn out real quick too you know
and
I guess it's kind of like the way it was
for child stars in the early days yeah
much like that they get used up they
don't they don't stay cute you know
everybody nobody stays young it's very
hard to stay on top well you yeah you
could even if you have millions of
dollars to spend on uh everything
getting pulled and tucked and uh
whatever uh injections to stay youthful
looking it's
you can't stop the march of time and
then accidents happen diseases happen
it's like you know [ __ ] happens we're
all doomed to eventually die so
would you would you describe yourself as
self-destructive
yeah in the past for sure I mean I
certainly don't to do much now to uh
some of the behaviors you've mentioned
are yeah I'm not I'm not uh
drinking or doing drugs but
um you know I eat unhealthy foods and uh
probably and I don't exercise
in any real way so um
uh the the thought of not living is it
becomes more and more appealing you know
that's what's your biggest fear
uh
oh god well just not being able to
breathe I guess you know because uh it's
a panicking situation
um and I've had that sometimes where I
wake up where I can't breathe kind of
like oh you're gasping for air
and
the Death part I feel it because I've
been near death uh for various reasons
for me I have a heart problem and stuff
over the years and when I feel like I
got close to death I actually had felt
very peaceful and wanted to go there
and I've heard other people say the same
thing who've had near-death experiences
once you get there I think the fear of
death
is is kind of what motivates people to
continue you know move along but
strangely uh the the peacefulness of
death
uh is very seductive too I mean so I
it's put me in a corner I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm supposed to be doing
with myself why am I here anymore and
what is the fate of the human race
because uh collectively we've destroyed
our environment and the generations
before us
uh well you know whether they're
ignorance or whatever they just
basically [ __ ] all over the planet and
now the air we breathe is toxic the sun
is is burning us it's hotter than it's
ever been before I mean
there's no denying what's go what's
happening and uh it sure is tempting to
want to
numb out and not think about it and find
a way to uh
to uh pleasure pleasure ourselves
speaking for myself
so stealing is uh
a thrill and
you get stuff
you get extra stuff but I think we all
just spent a little more of our time and
energy trying to make the world a little
bit better than it was before we were on
it uh-huh that could be very helpful
yeah well it's like in consideration but
I think what's happening now is like
more and more and more
uh positive reinforcement for that kind
of behavior exists people like Trump set
a tone that I mean just look at the
escalating incidents on airplanes and
customer service in general there's just
a lot more hostility and a lot of
rudeness stopped at McDonald's on the
way here there's always there's a and
they have to have a security guard at
the cashier's Stanton now you know
because the people are like so eager to
start a fight over anything like my
coffee's not sweet enough or whatever
you know I know and you see videos
online and I think that encourages
people to do it you know to uh do you
see there's like a whole channel of
Karen attacks or or even the male Cairns
whatever they're called the cabins maybe
but there's just so much uh
glorification of this of trash Behavior
it used to be funny but now it's so
common that it's just like get me out of
here are you are you pessimistic about
the future of mankind
yeah
I can't see how we could get out of this
unless some alien life force from
another planet a more sophisticated than
intelligent can come here and help us
maybe get us a new planet somewhere
um we have to I think what keeps us
going is is the hope you have to keep
hoping that there's something out there
that can help us and I suppose I'm
always looking for a savior of some kind
you know I I wish a hero would come
along but
the years keep passing and I still don't
I still not I still don't get what I
want or feel like I need and I lose hope
and I've
I've wondered about
uh how I could how I could end it all
safely without without paying but
what would you say 50 is the most
important thing you've learned in all of
your life
that everything changes everything uh
is temporary everything is temporary
good things are bad things so I mean if
I'm on a high I'd like to stay on a high
but
realistically uh that's not probably
healthy anyway if
because I've seen people who have had a
lot of great who seem like they've had
enviable lives
um but it's it's not that way things
things hardly ever are what they seem at
face value you talked about celebrities
and you know that life
but I think most people don't stop and
consider how
inconvenient all that is
I mean think about your daily routine if
you're going to the store or go
in for a walk if if you're recognizable
wherever you go
that would suck so much everybody wants
to maybe take a selfie or talk to you or
tell you how much they love you
which seems great like I wouldn't
wouldn't it be wonderful if everybody
loved me but sometimes you're not in the
mood to hear all that
sometimes you're not in the mood to put
on a show and and be uh or I'm not you
know but I have I have a
kind of a rotten personality I have a
I'd say stoic stoic personality I'm not
always in the mood to sparkle and shine
and smile
all right Pippi thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you for having
me and I wish you the best of luck